pas un endroit dans l'essence même est
de rester fermée de manquer si
cruellement de vie et on espère que ça
va pas ça va pas durer trop longtemps
mais voilà c'est désolant pas un rire
d'enfant ni aucun bruit de petits pas
sur les structures depuis leur
confinement
le parc de jeux de shérazade est de
nouveau fermée et la situation
financière de l'entreprise devient
extrêmement difficile ici en
l'occurrence nous avons 1200 m² c'est
l'une des cellules les plus grandes de
la zone commerciale
donc forcément le loyer au mètre carré
est extrêmement élevé les taxes
foncières
le sont tout autant l'acf la cotisation
foncière les tout aussi c'est vraiment
énorme tous les mois à débourser 15
mille euros de frais incompressibles
pour sherazade que les 1500 euros dette
de l'état ne suffisent pas à compenser
dans ce complexe d' escalade 2400 mètres
carrés
cette somme permet à peine un gérant de
payer le gaz et l'électricité
si on prend pas conscience qu'on a des
structures lourdes est importante et qui
sont pas des structures de communes qui
sont vraiment des structures privées
on pourra pas passer on pourra pas
passer ce deuxième confinement
sereinement et on sera certainement
obligés soit fermer nos portes et donc
effectivement c'est une ses tympans
d'économies qui va disparaître ces des
salariés king brett juste à côté de sa
salle d'escaladé christophe gomès
possède aussi un complexe multi
activités laser game simulateur de
pilotage escape game
il a tout misé sur le loisirs indoor et
a donc tout à perdre
on aimerait bien que les aides sont en
proportion avec nos investissements
qu'on ne considère pas comme des mines
des miséreux et qu'on nous donne pas une
petite
une petite aide mais des aides à la
hauteur de nos chiffres d'affaires
d'autant que le loisirs indoor ne sait
pas où se situer dans le calendrier des
réouvertures au 15 décembre comme les
cinémas ou au 20 janvier comme les
salles de sport le flou demeure pour ce
secteur en mal de considération